bonjour je suis devant un studio
d'enregistrement aujourd'hui pour
doubler un personnage du film bob
l'eponge le film aéro sort de l'eau je
connais bien je connais bien le titre
c'est le premier film bob l'eponge en
images de synthèse
voilà ça c'est ce qu'il m'a demandé de
faire un des personnages ou pas de toute
seule au grand jour qu est ce que vous
êtes prêts à doubler des mois tweete ses
combats en direct
nous avons beaucoup le sosie de carlos
reygadas ont le nez j'étais surprise
pour vous quelqu'un qui va venir
oui je vois même titre était sage si
vous avez bien suivi le fil tendu mais
effectivement il doit ya un super héros
va un petit peu nous surveiller pendant
qu en tant qu on double ouais donc voilà
il faut tout donner
m ardi me trouvais en sicile j'ai
toujours vu les making of ci c'est des
mecs qui faisait les doublages et
toujours cette baraque comme ça
mécanicien est venu de bron soit oui je
ne suis pas d'accord focalise étirements
boîte assez bon a lancé mouettes
[Musique]
quelque chose au monde qui serait pire
que les oiseaux qui parle c'est les gens
qui chantent
bon d'accord je promets de ne plus
chanter on vous le confirme il n'aime
vraiment pas du tout les oiseaux qui
chantent à a continué à lire s'il vous
plaît mais c'est le pirate cui la faim
et la motion après moi je cite barrages
et projets et l'histoire s'arrête là qua
non pour des îles au secours ablé mon
petit j'avais franchement j'adore sa
voix tendre aux femmes elle m'a dit des
mots des mots
j'adore tuer des mouettes et les manger
voilà la vraie bien mais le discours
était tout blanc et de toute une optique
un mois il fait bon jour métier le
pirate dans le comme ça c'est parti pour
en faire les musiques de bob l'eponge le
générique est une musique de rap de faim
voilà des mois qui rappe c'est aussi ça
[Musique]
c'est toi qui va commencer à faire
arrête gros nul de nous insulter arrête
gros nul de nous insulter et on a assez
de thé arrête on vole dans les airs on
sorte sur les mers quant à ton et sur ta
tête qui ne polluent l'air phoenix alors
si les plus vieux qu'à forcer à arrêter
le film trop long alors on tourne le
temps qu'on puisse finir notre chanson
on va faire maintenant c'est on va faire
le générique de bob l'épongé ce que ça
vous dit quelque chose qui vit dans un
ananas dans la mer c'est bob l'eponge ko
qui lit dans un ananas dans la neige
tombent les bombes
carrez qui pensent que vient il faire
carrière table et non jusqu'à vous avez
un souhait qui faut-il appeler brusque
arrêt qui n'a pas peur du gauche
y aller
et là c'était bien bravo je m'entends
vraiment un truc
elle vous plaît la fiche elle est très
belle et kitty yakin single when the
sequel to push cars est bon ça vous a
plu
c'était génial un bon gros doublage
comme on les aime
c'était un plan de m c'était un poids
non mais c'est surtout pour garder ça
qu'on était petit et jamais on ne puisse
dire un jour je doublerai sature génial
ça c'est moi j'ai super hâte de voir les
images dans une salle de cinéma
jade voir la fiche un truc de ouf on se
retrouve dans les salles sombres a très
vite
[Musique]
sylvie dans un canal avant l'anr au blé
punch carré tu pour te vient il faire
carrière problème on se garer